[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
hit
under the wonderful help of the State
Library our state librarian said
we have some money and we want to put it
to use on the reservation will you work
with our committee well we'll do hot
spots and we'll do more devices and
technology technology and I really had
to give them a reset to say you know our
families want books
all of the technology is wonderful but
if you don't have enough bandwidth in
your home or if you don't have any
the technology really doesn't serve so
let's purchase books and get them out to
the community in an old-fashioned way
we'll drive to a location that is
commonly used
the post office or the health clinic and
we'll give books away everybody else
wanted their technology for the state of
Wyoming and we've got our boats
the name is Moby bookmobile and you'll
notice the white pickup the white
trailer there's Moby Dick how many
Librarians do you know wear cowboy boots
and know how to hook up a trailer hitch
in Wyoming all of us
we visit the Indian Health Service
clinic in ethiti every Tuesday afternoon
and our main function is at the Fort
Washakie post office and everybody gets
mail at the post office there's no
street delivery so you've got an
automatic flow of traffic in and out of
the lobby our desire is to see that
literacy is an important part of
everybody's home and I think that brings
us to the question of why are we part of
this nnlm grant cycle when we're a
library we're not a medical facility but
we hope to bridge that Gap
Robin's submission was to support her
Moby bookmobile which at the time didn't
have much of a collection of health
related topics and so through funding
through our program she was able to
supplement her collection and she now
has a pretty robust collection of health
related books that are culturally
appropriate to the population that she
serves we select
Al Health Nutritional Health but also we
wanted to make sure we had books that
addressed emotional and mental health
[Music]
right off the bat they would ask do you
guys have any Native Books and they were
the first ones to go all the time
for many it might be their first time to
actually read
and identify with a book
the younger kids today are much better
prepared to live in Two Worlds if you
will you know the Shoshone world the
culture and the non-indian world
Chief warsky was the leader of the
Shoshone tribe
and he said I want my people to look at
that paper that white men look at that
is the way that we're going to keep our
land our water
and he was talking about education
[Music]